27 ans après le génocide emmanuel macron
souhaite normaliser les relations entre
paris et kigali
des échanges entre les deux pays sont
empoisonnées depuis près de trois
décennies par le rôle de la france dont
le massacre des tutsis survenu en 1994
la publication du rapport du clair en
mars dernier dénonçant la responsabilité
accablante du gouvernement français de
l'époque a permis de relancer le
dialogue entre l'elysée et le pays
dirigé par paul kagamé longe mémorielle
sera donc au coeur de la visite des
manuels macron alors que le rwanda
attend toujours des excuses de paris
le président s'adressera aux victimes de
génocide mais aussi aux rescapés
nous espérons trouver les mots justes
pour pouvoir parler à ces personnes
notre sentiment c'est que du côté de la
jeunesse africaine et de la jeunesse
française
il y as besoin de mettre des mots sur le
rôle exact de la france durant cette
période
nous allons répondre à cette demande de
compréhension mais ce déplacement revêt
aussi un enjeu économique
le président sera accompagné d'une
dizaine de chefs d'entreprises et par
les responsables de l'agencé française
du développement l'afd qui a relancé son
action au rwanda en 2019 au total près
de 120 millions d'euros ont été engagés
entre autres dans la santé l'énergie et
l'enseignement ces deux dernières années
un réchauffement à travers le prisme
économique amorcée dès 2018 lors d'une
rencontre entre les actuels chefs d'état
des deux pays
ils se sont mis d'accord pour travailler
sur des sujets concrets et d'intérêts
communs entre les deux pays
un certain nombre d'engagements ont été
pris à cette occasion qui ont
progressivement été mis en place depuis
l'arrivée d'un nouveau chargé d'affaires
à kigali le rwanda a eu des performances
remarquables ces dernières années et
peut être considérée comme une
plateforme potentiel de rayonnement
économique dans la région
lors de ce voyage les deux présidents
pourraient s'entendre sur le retour d'un
ambassadeur français à kigali où le
poste est vacant depuis 2015 l'occasion
pour emmanuel macron de concrétiser le
retour de l'hexagone dans une région
considérée comme l'une des plus
dynamiques du continent africain